alemania estaba decidida a escribir un
nuevo capítulo en los libros de historia
casi 30 años después del holocausto
cuando los juegos de múnich de 1972 se
convirtieron en uno de los momentos más
oscuros de la historia olímpica 8
miembros del grupo terrorista palestino
septiembre negro irrumpieron en la villa
olímpica y atacaron a la delegación
israelí matando a dos atletas y tomando
a otros como rehenes el superviviente de
la masacre soldada ni escuchó al líder
del grupo hablando con un oficial de la
policía ley de trades la oficial
intentaba convencerle y le dijo que
debían ser humanos este viaje un mes y
él le contestó que los judíos tampoco
son humanos no tiene ni idea mientras
las negociaciones se alargaban la
policía alemana ideó un plan
proporcionaron a los terroristas un
avión que los llevaría a ellos ya los
rehenes a el cairo los oficiales
disfrazados de tripulación de cabina que
esperaban a bordo dominarían a los
pistoleros pero el plan se cayó a último
momento diciendo que era demasiado
peligroso en el caos que siguió los
terroristas mataron a tiros de rehenes
israelíes murieron 5 terroristas y 3
fueron detenidos las autoridades
alemanas fueron criticadas por una
operación de rescate abrupta no
estábamos mal preparados no estábamos
preparados en absoluto de
750 años después los presidentes de
alemania e israel asisten a una
conmemoración conjunta
como parte de esta conmemoración quiero
reconocer los errores de juicio y la
mala conducta durante los juegos de 1972
en munich un acuerdo de compensación a
los familiares de las víctimas fue
alcanzado apenas la semana pasada cuando
berlín anunció que les entregaría 28
millones de euros a principios de este
mes las familias habían amenazado con
boicotearlas conmemoraciones alegando
que la cantidad que se les había
ofrecido inicialmente era demasiado baja